moving and shaking this morning PIMCO
bond guru Bill Gross you've probably
never seen him quite like this rocking
shades at a Morningstar conference in
Chicago Gross told the conference he is
a seventy year old version of Justin
Bieber also that he wants to go all
Manchurian Candidate on the reporters
and hypnotize them into thinking he's a
good guy on a serious note though Gross
said he is betting that market
volatility will remain abnormally low
PIMCO is forecasting a new neutral era
one with lower interest rates and lower
global growth while joining us for more
on Gross's forecast and his behavior is
Bloomberg economics editor Mike became
because Mike you and I've talked about
gross and sort of a slow implosion here
not only had his funds but his firm
itself what do you make of this well I
took to build quite often and I think
what's happening here is is he's had a
tough time with the fund it has been
down they've had a lot of redemptions
and then along comes the split with
Mohamed el-erian we will never know what
happened between the two but the press
reports have been that Bill Gross was
the bad guy in Mohamed el-erian was the
good guy and I think the combination of
the two things has grossed trying to
sort of mend his image in public yeah
lighten up a little bit get people to
smile and laugh some and at the same
time deliver the message that pemko is
still in good hands PIMCO is still
making money they are making money over
the last month but it has been a rough
period for them well really the only way
to sort of bring back your reputation
and and your image is to perform well
right that's the bottom line for
everybody and what they're doing now is
placing their bets on this theory of the
new neutral where markets are going to
be calmer and they're not going to make
a lot of money off of volatility which
of course is what the big banks are
complaining about they can't make any
money because nobody's trading and what
people think they're doing at PIMCO is
selling puts and calls and maybe options
spreads on the sp500 so they can take
advantage of a much more stable market
and sell bonds is sort of the
alternative to that